today the map will show a drag queen is
invited on the altar during a church
service but the pastor's justification
for this satanic display tells us more
than I think he intended to reveal also
antifa mobilizes for my event at the
University of Houston in a few days
Tulsi gabbard leaves the Democrat Party
the secretary of the army says the Army
isn't woke it's just
um inclusive which is like the same
thing in our daily cancellation Michelle
Obama is teaming up with an organization
that just put out the worst get out the
vote ad in the history of democracy all
of that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
stores have different price tiers for
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers but rockauto.com's
prices are the same for everybody and
they're reliably low for everybody
rockauto.com always lows offers the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like Airlines do rockauto.com
is a family-owned business serving Auto
Part customers online for 20 years you
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
Manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and Brake Parts
to tail lamps motor oil and even new
carpet so whether it's for your classic
or your daily driver you can get
everything you need with just a few easy
clicks delivered straight to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is remarkably
easy to navigate best of all the prices
are at rockauto.com are reliably low
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now I'll see all the parts available for
your car truck at rockauto.com and be
sure to write Walsh in there how did you
hear about this box so they know that I
sent you
my what is a woman College Tour
continues this week I'll be screening
the film at the University of Central
Florida tonight and then moving on to
the University of Houston now the
Houston event is apparently already
creating serious tension on campus as
the Houston ABC affiliate reports watch
Diaz could reach a boiling point
Thursday at the University of Houston
controversial conservative Matt Walsh is
speaking and showing his new movie some
of the trans Community believe the film
is an attack on them because of this
they're planning their very own event
but as ABC 13's nicknoterio discovered
it's one of the conservative group
welcomes
a lot of eyes will be on this U of H
building Thursday night inside a speaker
brought by a conservative student group
will showcase a new film we believe as
college students on a college campus
that that view is the minority we
believe that a majority of students do
believe in genders do believe in the
difference between man and woman outside
protest is expected to take place this
is in my opinion not a freedom of speech
issue but rather a hate speech and a
safety issue the concern by some and the
trans Community is the topic of the
speaker Matt Walsh's movie It's called
what is a woman Walsh says it's a look
at the gender ideology movement trans
activists say it's a film that attacks
them and others who perform gender
reaffirming procedures Eden Rose Torres
who's a trans woman or is this film
could generate anger towards her
community I'm going to be extremely
worried about the students of University
of Houston the students and the faculty
I they do not deserve to feel this
unsafe and be put at this much risk now
I just want to clarify that when I I
have described the film as a bombshell
documentary I didn't mean it literally
so you're not going to be getting any
physical danger whatsoever I promise you
also when I say that audiences have been
blown away and left stunned by the movie
um which is true these are also not
meant to be taken as actual physical
descriptions of their reactions these
are um metaphors and hopefully that will
put your your mind at ease though I
suspect that that's not the source of
the confusion here as we've covered when
they say unsafe they mean that their
understanding of the world and of
themselves is vulnerable when it's made
to confront contrary viewpoints so they
say unsafe but they mean really
destabilize their conception of reality
is fragile it's precariously at the top
of a stack of wholly unsupported and
arbitrary assertions and and
presuppositions
um they're terrified of anything that
threatens to knock the whole Tower over
that's what they mean
now there's something perhaps ironic
about this crippling fear on the left
given that the left's great project is
to itself destabilize and Destroy
knocking over whatever it can topple so
for a good example of this we go
elsewhere in Florida to Allendale
Methodist Church in St Petersburg which
recently played host to a drag queen
during Sunday services and this video
has gone viral the drag queen goes by
the stage name penny cost obviously a
sacrilegious play on the sacred
Christian holiday of Pentecost but his
real name is Isaac Simmons and he's a
candidate for ordination in the United
Methodist Church he's an associate
pastor he's also an atheist who
proclaims that the Bible and God are
quote nothing
Simmons makes these declarations in a
slam poetry performance posted to his
website where he proves that his
imitation of a poet is even less
convincing than his imitation of a woman
listen
look the Bible
the Bible is nothing
nothing but poetry pain and performance
the Bible is no more holy than Alan
ginsberg's House of life no more
peaceful than Oscar Wilde's requiesca
and Pache and no more stronger than
Tammy
days
eyelash glue God themself is no more
tangible than the cacophony of invisible
butterflies floating in new lovers
stomachs yearning to be set free from
the bondage of past harm and the lacks
of rightful mistrust God themself is
nothing
but if she were she would be yes
cleaning her way down the runways of
Paris and Montreal strutting on that
tightrope pulled taught between
absurdity and opulence balancing between
too much and never enough
there's a lot of cheap blasphemy going
on there but let us not allow the
heretical nonsense to distract us from
the fact that the Poetry judged on its
own merits is extremely bad no more
tangible than the cacophony of
butterflies floating and new lovers
stomachs yearning to be set free this is
the kind of line that a student in a
community college creative writing class
might come up with and then hopefully be
expelled for right on the spot it's
cliche upon cliche if I were to if I
were to utilize my own poetic metaphor I
would say that this guy has the
intellectual depth of an inflatable
kiddie pool tinted with urine and
pockmarked with dead beetles and
horseflies floating on the surface not
exactly Shakespearean either but at
least it's a little bit more descriptive
in any case Isaac Simmons of the atheist
drag queen Pastor showed up to perform
to perform at a a fake Church in Florida
a few days ago two young girls were
brought up on the satanic altar to be
used as props for this display and then
this conversation unfolded
do either of you have any questions for
Miss Pentecost
oh thank you
you like her eye shadow that's great
yeah yeah maybe she'll let you borrow it
when you're older when you're allowed to
wear makeup
well one of the things I think is great
about Miss Pentecost is she reminds us
that we we follow a God who calls us to
not conform to things of this world uh
that we're supposed to be transformed by
the renewal of our minds and that means
that what I think today may have to
change tomorrow if I continue to renew
my mind and it's so cool that we serve a
God that calls us to continue to grow
and continue to to change into something
new uh and to not be bound by the ways
that the world confines us sometimes
that we're supposed to live differently
now the apostate preacher there is
referring to and hideously mangling
Romans 12 2 which indeed warns us
against conforming to things of this
world and calls for the renewal of our
minds this actually means in our in
context if you read the sentences before
and after it is that we must live in a
way that is quote holy and pleasing to
God and we must use quote sober judgment
and avoid falling into pride and
self-regard
we're told to conform ourselves to the
body of Christ love what is good and
hate what is evil that's what that's
what the whole verse says um the verse
in other words warns against
precisely the sort of display we just
witnessed drag is among other things
profane ostentatious self-focused
prideful absurd
it is anything but the product of
humility and sober judgment
it's the opposite of the verse that the
pastor uses to defend it and of course
most importantly
drag is not a rejection of the things of
this world it is a thing of this world
it's a product
of the decadence and moral Insanity of
modern American culture
it's hard to think of something that's
more of the world than that it's also a
a a trend and a marketing gimmick
it is all of the things that Romans
chapter 12 tells us to reject
but what the pretend pastor at the
pretend church is really trying to say
is that drag especially when mixed with
church or with children or with both at
the same time is meant to break down
barriers it's an attempt to
um destroy or at least weaken cultural
guide rails and fences that have been
put in place
and that is certainly true this this is
all the left does after all
um except that the barriers the left
breaks down are barriers barriers of
basic human decency of um intellectual
and moral coherence of objective truth
it silences the voice of tradition tears
down all that was built by our ancestors
simply because it was built by our
ancestors therefore it must be bad they
reason
that's what drag is about it's what
gender ideology is about it's about
critical race theory is about
it's what everything on the left is
about
this is a sort of renewal that the
pastor was talking about
now people on the left they they might
even agree with most of my
characterization up to this point yes
they'll proudly Proclaim We are
fearlessly tearing down barriers and
we're we're claiming our independence
and our autonomy
because we're not conformists like the
rest of you
but what they leave out is that the old
barriers
you know those barriers that made sense
and which were rooted in natural law and
objective truth and uh Traditions
stretching back through the ages
they are not knocked down to reveal a
wider and Wilder landscape where people
are free to just Roam and do whatever
they want
no the old barriers are simply replaced
with new ones
and the new ones it turns out are far
more restricting and constricting
they're also arbitrary and
intellectually indefensible
so the barrier which says that you
should you know you shouldn't include
children in your cross-dressing
performance that goes away for instance
we're tearing that one down
but a new one which says that you should
not show a popular documentary on a
college campus
is put in its place
so you could dress and drag and dance
around kids but you can't show a
documentary dealing with a serious
subject to a bunch of college students
all sorts of new restrictions are put in
place
new fences are built
the new ones are all tenuous they're all
fragile
they blow over in a slight breeze
and whenever they do a million screaming
harpies will burst into tears claiming
that if we don't respect these new
boundaries people will die
so what's the lesson here we leave the
old ways behind
but we're not Freer it turns out
far from it
now let's get to our five headlines
another quick note about my Houston
event this is from Andy no I just saw
this report pop up he saw he says he
reports uh antifa in the Houston area
are rallying comrades to try and stop
Matt Walsh from speaking at the
University of Houston on October 13th
the screwston antifa group has claimed
responsibility for recent violence
outside the Katy Texas Church raising
money to help transition children
so that's what they're they're saying
they're going to mobilize they're going
to show up at uh at this screening of
the film
and it's a film that uh they in
particular need to see
um
here's what they they posted on their
social media platforms stop transphobia
at uh
although it's kind of funny because it
says stop transphobia at uh and it kind
of reads like at first it reads as stop
transphobia at uh
and then it looks like they just lost
their train of thought and forget where
they're supposed to stop transphobia but
anyway rally in protest Thursday October
13th 6 30 P.M
um
on Thursday far right bigot and
transphobed Matt Walsh will be on campus
we must oppose his hate
the majority of uh students and workers
reject this hatred we must organize the
largest possible counter protest to make
sure Matt Walsh and other bigots know
they're unwelcome
right
uh so they're going to try to show up
and and stop the
screening from happening and stop me
from speaking
now it's impossible like that's not
going to happen on my end I can tell you
that right now like there's nothing that
they can say or threaten that would make
me say well maybe we shouldn't show up
now whether this as it's intended to do
prompts the school to shut down the
event I certainly hope that doesn't
happen but I certainly can't guarantee
that it won't
um but this as always of course we know
this is what anti-fascists do if you're
against fascism you uh you make threats
and you use intimidation to stop people
from talking about things and from
seeing films
that's what the anti-fascists do
obviously
now on happier news this is from the
daily wires just former congresswoman
and Democratic presidential candidate
Tulsi gabbard said Tuesday that she was
leaving the Democratic party because it
had become an elitist cabal of War
mongers driven by cowardly wokeness
gabbard who represents uh rather
represented Hawaii's second
congressional district after serving two
combat towards the Middle East made the
announcement in a video posted to her
social media accounts early Tuesday
morning and this is now trending all
over the place and uh let's watch it
I can no longer remain in today's
Democratic party that's under the
complete control of an elitist cabal of
War mongers who were driven by cowardly
wokeness who divide Us by racializing
every issue and stoking anti-white
racism who actively worked to undermine
our god-given freedoms that are
enshrined in our constitution who are
hostile to people of faith and
spirituality who demonize the police but
protect criminals at the expense of
law-abiding Americans who believe in
open borders who weaponize the National
Security State to go after their
political opponents and above all who
were dragging us ever closer to nuclear
war
now I believe in a government that's of
the People by the people and for the
people
unfortunately today's Democratic party
does not instead it stands for a
government that is of by and for the
powerful Elite
now I'm calling on my fellow Common
Sense independent-minded Democrats to
join me in leaving the Democratic Party
if you can no longer stomach the
direction that the so-called woke
Democratic party ideologues are taking
our country
and I invite you to join me
well that's what needs to happen I mean
honestly I'm tired of people giving so
much credit to uh the supposedly
reasonable
Democrats like Cinema and mansion and uh
well I guess those are the only ones but
they get credit sometimes from uh from
the right because they take positions on
occasion that are outside of the
Democrat mainstream because the Democrat
mainstream is off the cliff into you
know
into far left insanity
uh but they get they get credit but then
they they remain in the Democratic Party
they stay aligned with it and ultimately
they do always end up bending the knee
when it really when it really matters
when it really counts they're going to
go along with what Democrats want
uh at a certain point you have to
realize as Tulsi gabbard has that the
Democrat Party is lost
it's just it's lost and so if you really
are a reasonable Common Sense person
and notice I say reasonable common sense
you don't even need to be a conservative
now I think the reason the common sense
will lead you to in that direction
but you don't need to see yourself in
that light
but if you're just reasonable and you
have common sense then you the Democrat
party's lost you and it's not coming
back
just like if you're on a if you're on a
ship and it's it's sinking into the dark
ICC it's not going to matter much if
you're the most reasonable one on board
it doesn't matter you know if you try to
warn the captain about the iceberg
before he hit it he didn't listen to you
uh well that that mattered before
maybe being the smartest most common
sense guy on the ship before it's
sinking and it's expert that might
matter but now it's going it's going in
the water
um and if you stay on then you're going
to be part of the the debris part of the
wreckage like everybody else
you have to abandon the ship it's too
late to bail it out and plug the holes
when the whole starboard side is
already in the water and I'm quickly
running out of uh ship terminology to
keep the metaphor going but you get the
you get the basic idea so this is good
now as as some people have pointed out
Tulsi gabbard is not a conservative on
every issue she also didn't say that
she's becoming a republican maybe she
will maybe she won't I don't know I
don't think that really even matters
that much I don't care if she does or
doesn't
uh is she a conservative on every issue
as far as I know no she's not
last I checked last last I heard her
talking about it she was pro-abortion
for example uh she's not exactly a gun
rights proponent
but the good news also is that uh is
that she's someone who can be reached
yeah I don't know this but
another five years from now wouldn't be
surprised it wouldn't surprise me if she
was also pro-life given that she is open
to listening to what people have to say
and she does have common sense
but I want you to notice something else
notice the difference
this is really the most
important thing in the most striking
contrast
because there have also been Republicans
on the other side over the last several
years
who have left the Republican party and
have made a big announcement about it
and said that I'm leaving and everything
and then and then they explain why
they're leaving and there are certain
Republicans who have announced that
they're leaving the Republican Party
about 46 times at this point
I think uh Jennifer Rubin at the
Washington Post
she has left the Republican party I
think I think most recently she was on
her um 1 000th occasion of leaving it
so but you you listen to them so when
Republicans say we're leaving the
Republican Party especially over the
last few years when this has happened
on almost every occasion
it's because of trump
and they tell you that they lay out
their reasons and it always comes down
to Trump when they're giving their
speech about why they're leaving they're
going to say the word Trump
or Maga
50 times because it all comes down to
this one guy it's this one guy they
don't like
a guy who's currently not even in
elected office
this one guy they don't like and that's
why they're leaving
now on the other hand listen to Tulsa
gabbard leaving the Democrat Party I
don't think she even mentions Joe Biden
at all maybe she did and I missed it but
that certainly was not the central focus
of her reasoning and if Joe Biden wasn't
on the scene you get the impression she
would still feel the same way
because she's leaving for a whole host
of reasons that all have that are
principled and they have to do with the
ideas and the the actual political
agenda of the Democrat Party which she
disagrees with
so she's not having a temper tantrum
because she doesn't like one person on
the Democrat Party side of it it's
because she the the entire platform she
rejects and She lays out all of the all
of the fundamental flaws
with the Democrat platform
so a very different sort of thing
all right so that was an impressive
speech there from Tulsa gabbard we'll go
to something a little bit less
impressive addressing the media
yesterday the secretary of the army
Christine warmuth
had some thoughts about the attacks on
wokeness and uh here's what she says
and one more thing Haley I would
emphasize is I think
um more broadly in terms of you know
soldiers coming from
um marginalized communities or you know
demographics that are not widely
represented in the Army that's part of
why we've got to emphasize positive
command climates and inclusion you know
we get criticized frankly sometimes for
being woke I'm not sure what woke means
I think woke means a lot of different
things to different people
um but first of all I would say if woke
means you know we are not focused on war
fighting we are not focused on Readiness
that doesn't reflect what I see at
installations all around the country or
overseas when I go and visit but I think
you know we do have a wide range of
soldiers in our army and we've got to
make them all feel included and that's
why a lot of our diversity equity and
inclusion programs are important
she just she looks and sounds like uh
like any Human Resources Director at
some Fortune 500 company or maybe not
even a company as impressive as that
like she sounds like she's any or or the
you know a guidance counselor
at some Middle School
that's what she sounds like and looks
like
and yet she's the secretary of the army
she's one of the people in charge of our
Armed Forces at the bureaucratic level
that's you can call it whatever you want
you call it woke and it's okay what you
call it but that's the problem
and and you know what she she says uh
well I don't know what this wokeness
thing is I don't care about the wokeness
I don't know if it's good or bad but uh
but the most important thing
is that we we make everyone in the Army
feel included
yeah that's that's wokeness okay Amy
just to make just be clear with you
that's what it is
that's what we're objecting to
make everyone feel included
when
that's the first of all that should be
the exact opposite especially going
through the recruiting process
and the training process
there should be very little concern for
people's feelings at all because that's
not going to help you on the battlefield
but just including people for the sake
of including them
that's not the appropriate way to go
through the recruiting process
for any Institution
let alone the military
in fact
recruitment and training and bringing
people in
to an institution whether it's the
military or something else is a process
of discrimination you are discriminating
you should have discriminating standards
there's no other kind of standard to
have if you have standards at all it is
going to be discriminating standards
because you are differentiating one
thing from another you're saying we want
this and not that that's you're
discriminating that's what it is that's
what the word means
I'm fine getting rid of uh wokeness we
don't need to talk about wokeness in the
military I mean it is woke but uh let's
just use the term that they use
inclusivity
they say that's not wokeness it's
inclusivity yeah it's the same thing but
fine I'm fine just talking about that
inclusivity inclusivity is destroying
the military just like it's destroying
so many other institutions so many other
once great institutions
because when you include everyone just
for the inclusivity for its own sake
throwing the doors open and saying
anyone can come it doesn't matter
there's no standards obviously that's
going to have a poisonous effect on that
Institution
all right uh this is from the daily wire
singer lizzo answered critics of her
weight and the fat acceptance movement
during a concert on Friday
yay the rapper formerly known as Kanye
West
we just call him Kanye West I feel like
we just still just call him that I don't
want to misgender but
um Kanye West on Thursday told Fox News
Tucker Carlson that lizzo whom he
considers a friend has been criticized
for losing weight something he found
extremely troubling and tied it to a
larger targeting of black Americans
lizzo told her fans at Toronto's Scotia
Bank Arena
I feel like everybody in America got my
mother effing name and their mother
effing mouth for no mother effing reason
I'm minding my fat black beautiful
business
that's that's what she said everyone's
talking about me I don't know why look
you know there have always been
of course pop stars who uh who are
provocative that's as long as pop music
has existed
it's thrived on that sort of thing you
know publicity stunts and everything
else
but it seems as though in the past
anyway
people who tried to get attention
and then got the attention they asked
for
would then use that attention for
whatever purpose they had in mind or
they would brag about the fact that
everyone's talking about them and how
famous they are you know it was it was
really you know very Brash and showy in
that way
now though we have this game
where they desperately flail around
looking for attention
and then as soon as they get it they cry
that's the process now so the first part
of it is not that different
lizzo now lizzo being morbidly obese
running around naked and everything in
thongs that's not something you saw in
pop music
up until the last few years
but the general thing of just like
flaunting around and and being half
naked and just trying to get attention
oh yeah that we've seen okay so I yes I
we could all agree that that's that's
pretty standard fare
but the next part is not I mean the next
the next part strikes me as pretty
uniquely modern
where you desperately desperately
clawing for attention which is all lizzo
ever does she desperately clung for
attention all the time
okay you don't whether you're morbidly
obese or not you don't walk around in
public and see through outfits unless
you want people to look at you
so when you're when you're going through
your closet and you've got all your
outfits there and you're thinking
yourself well you know I really want to
be Incognito today I don't want people
to notice me I just want to get in and
out I want to run to Walmart I got to
grab a couple things I need some new uh
you know sponges and Windex or whatever
from Walmart and I I don't want to be
bothered
well you're not going to then grab for
the see-through thong in that on that
occasion
maybe this analogy doesn't really work
that well because it does seem like
that's the sort of thing people do wear
to Walmart all the time but you get my
point generally it seems like if you
don't want attention you're not going to
go with that sort of uh get up and
that's what she does because she wants
the attention
and then she gets it and she just never
stops crying about it
because
that's what the attention is for it's
it's you know you want to generate the
attention
and then you want to convert there's
this conversion process attention on its
own doesn't do any anyone any good you
got to be able to convert the attention
into something
and we live in a in a
in a victimhood economy and so she
converts the attention into
victimhood tokens
that's essentially how it works
all right I had this story
on the docket here for a few days and I
want to finally um spend a couple
minutes talking about it
it's a horrifying story it's hard to
even read but uh maybe you've already
heard this a Tennessee mother of two
is now in stable condition with stitches
and bite marks over her entire body
after attempting to intervene when her
two pit bulls mulled her toddlers to
death on Wednesdays it was last
Wednesday
Kirsty Jane Bernard 30 was severely
injured by the dogs when she tried to
pull them off of her five-year-old
rather five-month-old boy Hollis Dean
and two-year-old girl Lily Jane just
outside of their home in Shelby County
both of the children were pronounced
dead at the scene Bernard's condition is
reportedly stable but the mother has an
uncountable amount of stitches and bite
marks over her entire body including her
face
uh the more details on the attack
that are you know circulating in the
media it's just it it it's Unthinkable
you can't even wrap your head around it
and
whether you have kids or not you
obviously see this is a horrific tragedy
when you do have kids then you can't
help but
sort of imagine yourself in that
situation and it's uh enough to take the
breath away
but it is another occasion for us to
for us to point out
that is it's like enough already okay
it's like how how many kids need to be
mauled to death
for the sake of pit bull ownership like
at what point can we all
just agree that it's it's too much and
these animals they don't belong
in the communities they don't belong in
in homes especially don't belong in
homes with little kids
you know there are basic facts here pit
bulls are responsible for almost all of
the deadly dog attacks in the country
every year okay almost all of them are
pit bulls almost all vast majority pit
bulls and rottweilers make up like um
you know six percent of the dog
population overall they account for
almost 80 percent of the Fatal attacks
and
pit bulls are 70 of that 80 so it's
almost all pit bulls and you're throwing
a couple Rottweilers and that's pretty
much it that that's all the dogs that
are killing people 's account for uh 70
like I said 70 of the Fatal tax and
that's why
every time you read a story you see a
headline about a dog fatally mauling
someone oftentimes a kid or an elderly
person
you could just assume ahead of time
that's a pit bull and you're almost
always right
okay when you start seeing patterns like
this it should tell you something when
you see a headline and dogs dog malls
fatal dog mauling and immediately say
that's a pit bull and you're almost
never wrong in that assumption
maybe that should tell us something even
with non-fatal injuries pit bulls are
responsible for well over half sixty
percent despite being such a small
portion of the overall dog population
and please don't respond by telling me
well you know poodles are even more
aggressive they bite more people poodles
don't Maul people to death
okay that might give you a little nip on
the hand and it'll hurt you might need
maybe you need to get stitches in a
worst case scenario
okay there there are also uh you know
maybe hamsters are more likely to bite
you than a pit bull that might be true I
don't know they're not gonna kill you
though is the point
it's the same reason we don't you're not
allowed to to purchase like a lion and
have it walking around in a community
now it doesn't matter you could all day
you could tell me well you know there's
only a there's only a two percent chance
that the lion would even attack you
I think that's probably not true but
even but if it is yeah but in the two
percent scenario I'm just dead like
that's it
so we're rolling the dice and and I
don't really want to roll those dice why
should I have to roll those dice
because you want to have a pet
um they are bred this way they just are
they are bred to have hair triggers and
when they attack to keep attacking until
the victim is dead not all dogs are like
that
you know again there's some dogs that
that might be inclined to bite also but
they're not going to keep mulling you
until you stop moving
that's just that's just how their bread
it's a statistical reality and you can
blame the owners all you want
but it's another fact that most of the
time when there's a pitbull attack we
hear that the dog never acted like this
before he's perfect they're perfectly
peaceful dogs that was the case in this
in this tragic case these were two pit
bulls that had both been owned by the by
the parents for like seven or eight
years and they're telling us had never
attacked anyone never shown any
aggression and then one day they kill
two people two two kids
so like even if it was true that most of
the pitbull attacks can be traced back
to bad ownership
that that doesn't help you any as a pit
bull apologist because like there are a
lot of bad owners out there
and so if my neighbor moves next door
with a pit bull I just have to trust
that he's one of the good owners
it doesn't seem very fair I got to trust
so for my own my children's safety I
gotta just hope that they're
very good owners
there are a lot of animals a lot of very
dangerous animals that if you're a very
good owner you can really mitigate the
risks of owning those animals
and yet we would still say you cannot
own those animals you especially cannot
not own them in a neighborhood and you
especially should not own them if you
have small kids in your house
I don't know how we don't put pit bulls
into that same category
and please all I ask you is anytime this
comes up
the first thing we hear is well you
sound just like people that are anti-gun
please don't do that please don't
embarrass yourself I'm asking you don't
do that
okay dogs are not guns these are two
different things you also have a
constitutional right to bear arms you
don't have a constitutional right to own
pets
if you did then you would be able to own
an elephant or or a tiger
you obviously don't have a
constitutional right to just own
whatever animal you want they'll be
ridiculous
you do have a constitutional right to
bear arms the other thing though is that
that guns
you know it's like what do we always say
as as the the gun rights crowd we say
that well look the gun's not just going
to pick itself up one day and start
shooting
blame the person right
well
hey Daw if we're comparing a pit bull to
a gun then then then actually a pitbull
is the kind of gun that just shoots
itself one day that just picks up and
starts shooting because there's a mind
of its own okay so you've got an
inanimate object
to which you have a you have a
constitutional right two
and then on the other hand you have a a
a dangerous animal with a mind of its
own
two different things
I just
I I don't see yes I've seen some of the
pictures people pass around of pit bulls
uh wearing shower caps or whatever
cuddling with with uh stuffed animals
and I've seen some of those pictures
and
yeah some of them are kind of cute you
know I can see a picture like that oh
that's cute I mean I can see a picture
of a lion and think the same thing
but
I don't think that the cuteness of the
animal
um
is is a good enough counter argument
for the bloodshed
I don't think it mitigates the bloodshed
or kids having their faces ripped off
so
let's just for God can we just
one of those issues that could be
bipartisan actual bipartisan issue can
we just like agree like it's a dangerous
animal it's killing kids it's just it's
not worth it it just doesn't belong in
in a human community
now let's get to the comment section
Rhonda says thank you for all you're
doing I'm a huge fan and supporter and
pray for your work and safety I'm
organizing a busload of people from uh
Loudoun I guess in Virginia to come to
your rally on the 21st is it on is it on
no matter what pauses the hospital does
will there be details coming regarding
parking how best to represent with signs
Etc wanting to help make a difference in
the best way possible yeah it's
absolutely still on so definitely bring
your um
your busload of people uh everyone bring
busloads of people rally is is not only
on but as we talked about yesterday I
think it's more important than ever
right now when you
you know when you're fighting for
something and you you you win a you win
a skirmish and I think that's what this
is it's an important Skirmish but we
want to Skirmish with the with the
hospital deciding to pause not deciding
but being forced to pause their gender
transition procedures on minors but when
you when you win that battle or that
Skirmish you don't just turn around and
go away like if you do that then it's
all for nothing you lost it's a you turn
a win into a loss by turning around and
saying uh all right well we're our work
year is done
so once you get that first Victory it's
all the more important to double down
and uh that's what we're doing so please
do come out as far as some of the
logistical details yeah we'll have uh
we'll have a lot more for about that
um very soon so stay tuned
all right
um
let's see Funk Soul Buddy says how peer
review Works you're gonna make money off
this oh yeah you oh hell yeah
what about you over there darn Tuten
we're all there
yeah it's that's basically peer review
well here's the real issue with peer
review is that
I mean there's that like as we've
discussed people involved in these
studies and some of the people peer
reviewing them are have a financial
interest in a certain outcome
and that alone just invalidates the
study completely like once you realize
that there are people involved in the
study people who've peer-reviewed the
study who are financially invested in a
certain outcome it should like ignore it
you don't even need to read it that's
out the window that's not science that's
propaganda it's absurd even pay
attention to it
um
but this speaks to the underlying issue
which even if there is a money involved
the the peer review process assumes
that the peers are credible and
trustworthy
so the process of peer review and
getting peer review it can turn into a
sort of like a peer pressure thing
because this all it it assumes that that
your peers are are right in general
um and have not been compromised
and that's not the case when it comes to
gender ideology so the
the therapists the psychiatrists
psychologists the doctors surgeons
endocrinologists
many people in all these fields are
totally compromised
and they have bought into this
ideologically and they've also as we
said bought into it financially
and then we hear about well like there's
a study and they all said it's valid who
gives up
a blankety blank what they say doesn't
matter
yes I did just say who gives a blankety
blank I did
that happened
um someone
creative name says what's sad is Matt
isn't actually the smartest man on earth
he isn't the best person to have on your
side in an argument it's just everyone
else is so stupid it makes them appear
like the smartest man on earth
he does still have more balls than me
and is making a greater impact on the
world than I probably will ever make
thank you Matt Walsh for just speaking
the truth uh
well I'm not going to agree with the
last part of that because who knows what
kind of impact you can make other words
you can make a great impact but the
first part I will agree am I the
smartest man on earth not even close in
a you know objectively speaking am I the
always the best person to have on your
side in an argument no I wouldn't say
that I am
um
and that's why I always say you know we
we live at a time right now
sort of the advantage that we have with
with the whole world going insane and
the left going insane is that you don't
need to be you don't need to be a genius
to you know to engage and to get in
there and to make arguments and to win
the arguments if you needed to be a
genius I would not be
in front of this camera right now and
you would not be listening to me
um all right
Paul says Matt Columbus technically
didn't discover the new world for the
Europeans Norway had known about America
for nearly 500 years at that time thanks
to Eric the Red who discovered and
landed on Greenland and Leif Erickson
who discovered and landed on Mainland
North America
yeah that always comes up with Columbus
now first of all the fact that um
the fact that there were
uh Vikings
centuries before
who had spotted or even landed on the
mainland North America that in no way
undercuts the significance or the
impressiveness of Columbus's uh Journey
but the other part of it is that like
they didn't
establish lasting colonies on the
mainland of North America
and um
Columbus did so that's that's part of
the discovery process is you have to go
and find the place
um but then you also have to establish
the contact and establish uh colonies
and that's that's part of the process
so
doesn't take away from Leif Erickson not
saying it does but it also doesn't take
away from Columbus
uh and we know that this is the case
throughout history the discovery is uh
is a process and you know it's it's very
rarely that just one guy all on his own
just stumbles across something or
discovers something there's always you
know it's always a process of building
and there are multiple people who can
you know arguably take credit for
certain aspects of the discovery that's
that's it's always been that way
um
let's see Brando says Matt Lauren
Southern is making content like the
daily wire is has been doing so for
years I'm sure she would appreciate a
huge corporation like you guys giving
her a shout out just saying she makes
Incredible content I know she just put
up a video with a d transitioner uh
herself that's on her Channel you should
go check out big Lauren Southern fan for
sure she does great work and finally
Milton says Matt your attacks on
Christian pastors are unfair and
disappointing it's not a pastor's job to
be a culture Warrior their job is to
Shepherd their flock in their churches
your generalized statements are uncalled
for and strike me as unchristian okay
first of all criticizing Church
leadership is one of the most Christian
things you can do in the world
historically speaking there's a long
tradition of Christians
criticizing and in very harsh terms
oftentimes Church leadership uh you know
there there are multiple just put into
perspective there are multiple Church
fathers and old Saints of the church who
are credited with
talking about how hell is the roads of
hell are paved with the skulls of
Bishops okay that that's the kind of
language that has been used to describe
Church leadership when they're failing
at their job and and that's what we
should be doing we should be holding
them accountable
um you say that pastors aren't called to
be culture Warriors I could not disagree
more I mean what are you talking about
they live in the culture don't they and
so are they going to fight for it or not
I I don't even understand how you could
draw a distinction between no I'm
worried about the shepherding my flock
not the culture
they're part of the culture they live in
the culture
okay unless you're going to take them
off and you're all going to go to some
island in the Pacific somewhere and and
start your own commune or something
um unless you're going to do that then
you've got to worry about the culture
and that's what we're all called to do
we're all called to fight for the
culture
and if Christian pastors and church
leaders are not going to do it
then who is
well there maybe will be some people who
step into the Gap but then the problem
as we talked about yesterday is that
sometimes these uh these Christian
leaders who have who have failed in the
job or have not done it or have not been
effective enough then other people step
into the Gap to fill that void and then
those same people who failed in the job
turn around and start criticizing those
who stepped into the void don't do it
that way do it this way
but hey there's room up here why don't
you come up here and do it where are you
oh I'm not worried about that I'm
worried about my own flock
and also these pastors that are worried
about their own flocks in their Church
most churches in America are dying okay
so I can't even accept even if I were to
agree with you that I'll forget about
the culture just worry about your own
flock even that's not working most
churches are dying
so yes there are some good Christian
leaders and pastors certainly there are
there are some very very good ones
um but as a whole the proof is in the
pudding here and and then that's the
point
well if you know me you know how much I
love Halloween and how excited I am to
dress up for the holiday now I I may
have to settle for the uh one of the
mill superhero costume but uh you know
that's usually what I go well I was
hoping for something more creative this
year I always get really creative on
Halloween but I don't know if that's
gonna happen this year but there's still
hope for you this Halloween you could be
the star of the year's breakout hit
documentary what is a woman that's right
you can head over to I have no idea
where this is going what is this head
over to dailywire.com shop to get your
very own Matt Walsh Halloween costume
do I get to approve this so we're
putting a costume of my likeness on the
site and no one even told me I don't
know what it looks like
be sure to post on social media and tag
me in the daily wire to show off your
costume yeah please tag me so I know
what the hell it is because I don't know
what it is
do I do I get to consent and being made
into a costume I don't get to consent
it's just I would just made it to a
customer no one even asked me
I'm not sure that I want anyone to do
this
anyway you might even make it on the
show remember not all heroes wear caves
this one wears a sandwich board luscious
beard and contrarian attitude not
included so there's no beard included
this is a Matt Walsh costume
what
okay it's like if it's a Freddy Krueger
costume you don't have the you know the
spiky hands or whatever he doesn't want
the spike hands right
um also also
also this George Floyd's death literally
set the world on fire divided America
and gave rise to the activist group
black lives matter they raised 80
million dollars through fundraising but
no one ever asked where the money went
until now on Wednesday October 12th
Kenneth zones will reveal the truth in
her new documentary the greatest lie
ever sold exclusively on daily wire plus
Candace travels to Minneapolis to meet
the people who knew George Floyd and
Derek shovin
and then she follows the money to find
out just where it did and did not go
after more than two years of the
mainstream media ignoring the story the
answer will shock and surprise you the
longer the media stays silent the louder
we get and the more momentum we gain so
your daily wire Plus Membership goes a
long way to ensuring that folks like
Candace Owens myself and everyone here
at the daily wire has a megaphone and
can keep creating important content like
this so free speech is our greatest
weapon remember we're speaking for you
we're fighting for your values too we
need to do it together as a team if
you're not a member yet go to
dailywire.com Walsh to subscribe and
join us today and tune in this week to
watch Candace owens's new documentary
the greatest lie ever sold exclusively
on daily wire Plus
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know there are things in the in this
life of ours that are simply made for
the daily cancellation destined for it a
story Written in the Stars Before Time
began sometimes people in events come
together in such a way as to combine and
form something so obnoxious and so
cringy and so vile and so stupid and so
hilarious
um in all the wrongest ways that it's
not even necessary for me to say
anything and explaining why I'm
canceling it though I will still still
you know say things lots of things
because this is a podcast and that's
what I do here without further Ado here
is the story from Fox it says former
First Lady Michelle Obama's voting
initiative is partnering with a dating
app that made a video titled
no voting no [ __ ] with a v
um now you've probably already heard
more than enough but you're going to
hear much more far more than is
necessary or decent I have to tell you
so continuing the voting initiative when
we all vote announced uh that it would
be working with the BLK dating app on
October 4th and doing voter registration
activations within the company the BLK
dating app is designed for black singles
looking to date according to its website
on October 4th the organization released
a video encouraging black voters to go
to the polls titled no voting no [ __ ]
which features Rashad Spain known as
Saucy Santana and Katrina Taylor who is
known as Trina
so just to make sure you understand
Michelle Obama who used to be the first
lady of the United States is partnering
through her voting initiative with a
dating app which just released a get out
the vote rap song starring something
called Saucy Santana in which black
singles are encouraged to Ransom their
bodies sexually in order to convince
people to vote
so now you're all caught up that's
what's happened if you think you're
gonna get you're going to get through
this segment and Escape it without
actually having to hear the song well
you don't know me very well because here
it is
[Music]
was heavy
no
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to hit this booty better do
your civic duty
he says quoting I believe John Adams
actually that's not exactly what John
Adams says here's here's what um John
Adams said just comparison's sake here's
what John Adams said in encouraging
those eligible to vote here's what he
said
quote it becomes necessary for every
citizen then to be in some degree a
Statesman and to examine and judge for
himself of the tendency of political
principles and measures let's examine
then with a sober and manly in a
Christian spirit let us neglect all
Party Loyalty and advert to facts let us
believe no man to be infallible or
impeccable in government any more than
in religion Take No Man's word against
evidence nor implicitly adopt the
sentiments of others who maybe deceived
themselves or may be interested in
deceiving us
now those are those sorts of things our
founding fathers said about voting we
used to be a nation that produced the
sorts of men who were capable of
speaking like that and saying those
kinds of things now we rhyme civic duty
and booty
and I didn't even get to the most poetic
part because the girl rapper or uh the
other girl rapper or whatever that was I
don't know what exactly going on but uh
she sings in her verse quote
don't stop now stuff my Ballot Box again
but my homegirl through put the Buy in
partisan
politics be so nasty make me want to
flirt you show you how to be a poll
worker uh legs in the air I don't care
that I believe was adapted from the
famous defense of democracy offered by
the ancient Greek ruler euclides
um at least that name sounds like an
ancient Greek guy I don't really feel
like Wikipedia but anyway Trina sauce or
whatever her name is is
you know obviously going for some kind
of sex and voting metaphor
um I guess which makes the legs in the
airline all the more curious
it's like I understand that in the
sexual context but why would you put
your legs in the air while voting
you know you're supposed to make your
selection using your your hand right I
mean use it on the voting machine not on
on yourself
now what are the problems with all this
aside from you know the obvious
sanitation issues well for one thing
Democrats have again put their bigotry
of no expectations on full display it is
in some ways easy for me to laugh at
this because I don't identify as black I
don't identify that way anyway and
therefore I'm not the one being degraded
and insulted here this is the kind of
patronizing lowest common denominator
humiliating nonsense that the left saves
for their favored victim groups there's
a reason for that of course because in
order to manipulate these groups they
need to be victim groups and if you want
them to retain that status you must
encourage all of the worst Tendencies
and behaviors while discouraging and
showing open hostility to the best
this is the leftist approach to all
groups black people women gays Etc
except straight white men because when I
talk about victim groups I'm saying like
every group on the planet except for
straight white men we straight white men
we are merely villainized and
scapegoated 24 7. that's what we get
it's not always fun but I prefer that to
the kind of psychological warfare they
wage against every other demographic
secondly on the other hand
I am somewhat grateful for this campaign
because it reveals in all of its
semi-literate horror the fundamental
absurdity of nearly all modern get out
the vote campaigns which you know how I
feel about get out the vote efforts I am
opposed to all of them after all why
would we want people to vote just so
that they can get laid how in the hell
does that benefit Society or the country
or democracy
what exactly is the long-term or short
short-term social benefit of convincing
people to vote on that basis alone
why do we try to drive voter
participation at all if somebody is
clued in and they're engaged and they're
informed and uh and and all of that then
they're going to vote anyway you don't
need to tell them to do it
if they aren't why would we encourage
them to vote
I don't think any get out the vote
effort
has ever actually succeeded in
encouraging the kinds of Voters you
actually want because those sorts of
Voters the informed and engaged one
again they don't need none of them
informed engaged uh people who are
interested in their civic duty none of
them have ever
encountered a get out the vote campaign
and then said to themselves you know
what I think I will I think I will vote
I mean after all if you want to get the
booty you got to do your civic duty
no one has ever done that if they're
informed and engaged it's only ever the
morons who are going to be motivated by
that
so how has democracy served by by this
how is it served by sheer participation
and what other context would we
encourage people to do something just
simply to do it whether they're equipped
or informed or competent or not
well College admissions is the other so
sending kids to college is the other
context so voting and sending kids to
college those are the two things where
we say just do it whether you're ready
for it or not
so who is this helping
well the answer of course is that it's
helping the ruling class it's helping
those in power stay in power it's
helping Michelle Obama's friends just
like it helped her husband when he was
in office having armies of
self-interested morons and ignorant
drooling buffoons vote is a is a boon to
corrupt politicians and the ruling
Elites and nobody else
they would certainly love it if you came
out to vote simply so that you could
have sex later that night
voting with your genitals perhaps
literally in Trina's case uh just means
you aren't using your brain which means
you're incredibly easy to use and
exploit and manipulate
and that's what this is really about as
always
and that is why the no voting no [ __ ]
with a V campaign
is canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block
uh talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]